I did see the Mario movie
did anybody Dove saw it I saw it Shifty
side Shifty saw it you guys didn't see
it at all no shifting so
um
I'm I'm right now
I'm right now
throwing my hat in
oh to play Waluigi literally I think God
did that for you to be honest with you
yeah
you might be right about that got
through your nose in the ring
it might be around Jesus bro but I would
like to play Waluigi in the Mario
Brothers 2 movie I say Mario not Mario
you said Mario a couple times nah be
like Andrew said Borat he got it I say
borax money now but I say Mario oh you
said Borat or some [__] Borat I say
Borat yeah Borat that's not it's
supposed to be borax but New Yorkers say
Borat no we say Borat I say Mario it's
Mario do I say Mario you said Mario
whatever it's the Mario Bros listen
this movie
um there we go shipping yeah so this
movie uh first of all great a lot of fun
more you were asking earlier you're like
is it a kids movie or is it one of those
cartoons that's kind of like four adults
Shrek or zootopia yeah right that has
like a sophisticated plot line and also
a childish one this is just for kids
okay this is just for kids but what I
will say is this the way that they shoot
it
is really smart and interesting because
at times it turns into the video game
like they'll shoot something and then
make it 2D and you'll see the characters
running across like a cityscape and they
have to jump on things and then go down
Etc and uh there's a time where like
Mario is learning how to exist in the
world and he's failing and it reminds
you of when you first played Mario when
you're jumping off [__] and learning the
rules and and I think they do a
fantastic job and then [__] uh what's
the Jack Black
she's great he makes the bad guy likable
he's so good he's like Bowser too good
he makes Bowser likable and they do it
on purpose where like you don't hate
Bowser too much like the movie is great
for kids the bad guy's bad but he's like
more naughty than he has been fun to
take kids and it's algebra for an adult
I went for the nieces and nephew if you
have that go I mean it was yeah it was
great and then they got over the whole
uh accent Scandal pretty pretty well
don't you think oh yeah what was what
was the accent Scandal I'm sorry
insulting to Italians they made Italians
look like a bunch of goombas right like
the whole they're like eating pasta and
then no but before that the Scandal was
like John Leguizamo and folks were
saying like it's Chris Pratt playing you
know these they're white guys playing uh
they want rolls that's what uh any
Puerto Rican anytime you see an actor
complaining about you know
representation they just didn't get a
role yeah but he's not Italian right
that's what confuses me yeah
yeah but wasn't he Mario or Luigi in
like the old old one yeah you shouldn't
have been that [__] either oh so he
that's hysterical yeah I think he's just
mad cause like yo he won't ask him to
run it back yeah yeah but in general the
Italian stuff they got over it that they
played it cliched in a commercial and so
they were making fun well they also when
the family dinner was there but whatever
it's not that bad I mean like one
Italians have a good sense of humor
about this [__] but also like
the Chris Pratt and then the guy Charlie
is that Charlie Day yeah Charlie Day
great Charlie Day plays Luigi and
they're great and then Sebastian
Maniscalco plays this guy Spike and he's
great yeah he like Pops in in a few
different scenes he's [__] hilarious
and uh it's just a really fun movie do
you wish Mario's voice was more like
quintessential Mario
he plays that up
so it's in the commercial so the
commercial is really good I don't want
to give away too much of a movie but
basically they put out a commercial
because they're trying to you know uh
get attention for their Plumbing
business and they put on these like mock
Italian voices thank you so he said
Mario and then they acknowledge it they
go did we go too far with the voices
yeah so the characters are acknowledging
that they're not going to speak in that
way but they did for a certain reason
yeah that was smart it was really smart
so they get around it but it's just a
fun [__] movie and obviously we grew
up with these video games they wrapped
around our whole childhood and like
you'll see little things in it like
you'll see a Yoshi pop up and they're
like oh that's it but it's not too much
that's cool you know like toad is cool
it was brought it up to me that like
they were doing screen tests with the
Mario accent as like the traditional
Mario accent for all the dialogue yeah
and that it was uncanny and kind of
weird like it fits for like little
taglines like yeah a whole an hour and a
half of that I was just thinking that
would give me a headache yeah also this
is like Japanese people's idea of what
Italians are it's racist as hell yeah
video games were racist Mario's based on
this like a super that was at a building
in New York and then with the the
Japanese execs yeah this is what we
think Italians are just like if you
watch Mike Tyson's punch out like every
one of those characters is like racist
as hell this is back in the day where
you could kind of be like incredibly
stereotypical in video games because
they just look at that yeah but they
also looked at them as an extension of
cartoons uh so if you watch like old
cartoons they didn't have time to
explain the complexity of characters
right they just be like okay here's
Brown guy yeah
Johnny Quest exactly yeah yes yeah yeah
so
I don't know I thought it was I thought
it was like fun and cool my wife
obviously different generation than me
yeah and I don't think she grew up
really playing the games as much like
she played Mario Kart yeah there's even
an homage to Mario Kart in it which is
kind of fire and um so yeah I just
thought it was cool like I would
recommend you go see it but set your
expectations at this is a kids movie
that you're gonna watch not this is
zootopia and it's gonna describe complex
racial Dynamics yeah everyone go to
illumination and Instagram and uh
petition for Schultz
in this one no there's no Wario no
Waluigi I think that you bring those
characters in later yeah the whole
world's being created this is
illumination that the Despicable Me
minions what else did they do they did
uh
oh uh uh Singh
and sing uh what is the other thing with
minions the guy grew uh oh that's
Despicable Me yeah yeah you think you
have what it takes me while Luigi I
think I do I'll be honest with you guys
I've never
seen
him in a game I've never played with him
I didn't even know who the Waluigi was
until the internet started saying I'm a
cookbook I didn't know what the
character was because I never played
them and I never played it yeah we were
out of video games at that point I think
are out of Mario at least
it's not in the old Mario Karts
I think he might have been in the old
ones I don't think so yeah
Yoshi a lot not in our Mario Kart Wario
you couldn't even be Wario in the old
Mario Kart it was just Yoshi Mario Luigi
Princess Toad Bowser wow all right well
it obviously the voice acting takes more
than just looking like them you gotta
sound like him let me see what he sounds
like
Waluigi time
Waluigi time that was really good yeah
all right that was really yeah you got
it
that's the jump bro okay keep going next
one wow wow
oh yeah oh yeah it's uncanny
you do that noise already actually I've
heard that noise what I do it's called
39.
[Applause]
that needs a little work yeah
does he got words yo I don't think so if
I want this rule
dying
this is done bro if that's all I got to
say they got to give me this roll
immediately